okay so it's 9:00 a.m. so good morning
from the west coast I'm Alex Bui
co-director the bd2k centers
Coordination Center and so this morning
I have the pleasure of introducing dr.
Karl Kesselman as the speaker for
today's be bd2k guide to the
fundamentals of data science dr. Karl
kesselmann is the deans professor at
university of southern california and
director of the informatics systems
research division at the information
Sciences Institute ISI he's well known
for his work in great computing and has
led several an air age data consortio
over the years one of those estimates
more recent interests is an election on
in creation of digital asset management
systems for scientific discovery and in
this light he's going to be talking
today about fair principles and its
application in daily tasks for those
listening in if you have questions for
dr. Kessler please type them in the chat
box and if we have time at the end we'll
go through some dr. Kesselman it's great
to have you speaking with us this
morning and I'm looking forward to
hearing more about your perspectives on
fairness implementation the floor is
yours great thank you very much so I
thought we would start by just outlining
the goals here for the top today I
thought it might be interesting to I'm
not gonna focus so much on directly the
research that I'm doing and the and the
details of some of the things that we're
doing here with respect to eqk but I
thought it would be useful to maybe talk
a little more generally about the role
of data in scientific discovery and some
true friends that are emerging with with
how to manage data in the process of
scientific discovery particularly a lot
of this driven by bd2k in big data and
my experience has been that a lot of
kind of scientists who are doing even
data analysis data generation doing lots
of data-driven science there's been a
lot of work and a lot of thinking
how one should go about managing that
process yeah and I realized that that
especially people who were more domain
oriented along a biomedical Discovery
tend not to be aware of some good
thinking and ideas that of God and so I
thought I would spend some time
reviewing background and trends of
what's happening in data management that
I think are gonna be especially relevant
to this audience in the kind of your
daily practice so you know what I hope
to get out of this talk is is and I
apologize if people in in the audience
actually know this stuff already but you
know what I would hope we get out of
this is some recognition as to how to
adapt your data management and data
collection practices especially driven
by data oriented discovery and big data
and you know how you might you know take
away some practical things or at least
some ways to think about what you're
doing that will you know I think is
important so with that is our goal and
then I will show you something that
brings some of these ideas to practice
so with that as kind of the goal what
I'd like to achieve let's proceed
following that is following so I'd like
to start actually you know with maybe an
existential question take a step back is
what does it mean to have a scientific
result and maybe this is obvious but
it's probably worth thinking a little
bit about so it's at a high level a
scientific result is something that
other people know about right so you
know this is if the tree falls in the
forest and nobody knows about it does it
actually fall so we are concerned about
communication sharing our results but
more importantly it's important that
others are able to validate that result
so and we can break that down into into
kind of three things
one is that we need to be able to
reproduce the method that was used to
create that result and achieve the same
answer right so that we want to be able
to in some sense repeat that what was
being done we we would also you know
ideally like to across the holiday which
is we would like to get the same result
using a different method and that way we
know what we determined is actually true
in some sense and then ultimately the
result should be something that we can
reuse to create a new method and as a
foundation for attaining achieving new
scientific results
so hopefully this these observations
should be obvious to you and here's a
here's a nice quote from from somebody
who was involved in kind of that the
theory of science which is non
reproducible single occurrences are of
no significance to science so I want you
to take this to heart right if you
produce result and it's non reproducible
arm and it's a single occurrence then
this is scientifically irrelevant all
right so we should all be saying well of
course right if we're doing science the
whole purpose of science is to let
people know what we've done and allow
them to reproduce our results so why are
we even having this conversation well it
turns out that even though this is
obvious we're not achieving this goal so
here's some results from the science
paper I'm sorry a nature paper that was
published in 2016 and and you actually
don't have to go very far this these
things are showing up in the popular
literature there's a you know articles
on NPR and and the BBC and so on about
the reproducibility of scientific
results and there's been studies that
show that one in ten papers has a the
results of one in ten papers can be
reproduced so in May 2016 there was a
little
kind of article in in nature where they
went off and surveyed 13 1,300
researchers 15 1500 researchers right
and here's the direct quote from that
patron paper in nature more than 70% of
researchers have tried and failed to
reproduce another scientist experiments
and no more tellingly this is really
damming more than half we're able to
reproduce their own experiments right so
even though the previous slide should be
well of course that's obvious when we
look at what's going on in practice
that's not what's happening all right so
not only can't we reproduce other
people's results we cannot even
reproduce our own results all right so
let's look at a breakdown so this is you
know in nature the question was raised
is is there a crisis and what we see is
that I mean depending on the degree of
crisis 80% of the scientists surveyed
said there's a crisis actually this is
90% said there's a crisis and reproduce
feasibility right we're over half of the
scientists survey said there's a
significant crisis well those are pretty
dramatic words to say there's a crisis
and if we would look at again from the
survey they asked you know what is
things that contribute to this crisis
and what we see is that there's a lot of
issues that contribute and so we can't
um we can't put our fingers on any one
thing so it goes everything from bad
luck - fraud - cherry-picking your data
but I think there's kind of two things
here that I'd like to focus on that are
especially relevant to beauty today so
one is the methods or code are
unavailable right so we can't reproduce
because we don't have that documentation
of the methods or code in in in a
meaningful way and then secondly
lack of availability of data I'm gonna
interpret this a little more broadly
than just raw data to be just general
lack of access to data right so these
are and actually if you look at it these
are two pretty significant factors
showing up kind of at the 80% level in
terms of the results of the reporting of
this survey right and so again there's a
lot of reasons why we can't reproduce
things you know it's a little surprised
to learn that major source of lack of
reproducibility of biomedical results is
is bad antibodies they just don't work
and you know as a result of that the NIH
is requiring antibody you know reagent
validation procedures to be included as
part of proposals atrophy exhibit so but
you know we're not necessarily talking
about you know wet lab experiments here
how is how are these things the notion
of reproducibility relevant to all saw
in the bd2k community well I think you
know what we need to think of is that
since we yeah
in many cases analyzing data or where
computationally or we're doing things
computationally now really what we're
doing is we are conducting experiments
with data and we need to think about the
same kind of experimental rigor that
takes place if we were sitting in a
bench or running a clinical trial that
same kind of rigor and experimental
design and documentation needs to take
place when we think about the generation
consumption and analysis of our data
right so and I would argue that as we
move to an increasingly computational
based environment and as we're being you
know overwhelmed by data and new
analytic methods which is the
underpinning of the you know the whole
idea behind bd2k the
roll of data in and either the
reproducibility or lack of
reproducibility in our experiment only
going to get more important so let's try
to break this down a little bit and
think about what does it mean to have
reproducibility about data what kinds of
characteristics would we like what can
we do to enhance our reproducibility
around data so you can think about this
and kind of splitting it up into I've
got kind of two main issues or points
that I think are worth thinking about
one is at kind of any level data is only
going to be useful right just having the
ones and zeros or the numbers in and of
itself is essentially of no use if I
give you a pile full of numbers those
are essentially means to me in the only
way that there's going to be meaning or
useful the data will have utility if I
can figure out some way kind of where
the data is so you get my hands on the
on the numbers what it is and what these
numbers represent and then ultimately
how it was created because so if you
think about it only if I know oh you
know how to get my hands on it what it
is that I'm trying to get my hands on
and how it was produced right then if i
if i don't have that then this whole
notion of reproducibility is really a
non-starter so we need to think in the
in and i'm sure again if we think about
it maybe we're all doing some of this in
our daily practice and but i think
there's value in thinking about these
issues a little more explicitly and
thinking about you know how does this
structure the way we set up our our
computational laboratory the second
thing I'd like to comment on is when we
think about reproducibility of data I
think there's a tendency to focus on
publication as the main artifact for
which there has
to be right so we think about when we
send that thing off the nature then we
have to document what we've been doing
so our protocol can be you know
reproduce then computationally I think
we often think that way and many of our
experiments we think that way
now if you think about it though when we
do design a clinical trial that's
actually in some sense the exact
opposite clinical trial we explicitly
lay out the protocol and the analysis
and the sample size the selection
criteria and all that kind of explicitly
ahead of time and data is collected you
know with that in mind now of course
that's a very rigid and painful process
of doing that and it's not conducive to
kind of more experimental discovery
based imitation but there's maybe some
lessons to be learned from that and so
my point is as we think about
reproducibility reproducibility is not
something you tack on at the end when
we're ready to publish reproducibility
is something that has to imbue the
entire experimental process whether
those experiments involve growing cells
or whether those experiments involve
writing code we need to be thinking
about reproducibility throughout the
entire lifecycle of our data that's
everything from the initial acquisition
whether that's experimental acquisition
or that's that you know acquisition by
making simulated data that has to be um
applied at every step in the process
that involves computing an analysis and
then ultimately at the end of the day
that also involves thinking about at the
point of publication how do we promote
reproducibility at that point there so
that's kind of a little bit about maybe
the philosophical framework in which
were we're starting with so you know how
can we bring that to bear and how does
that impact us in our daily practice
well I'd like to start to get a little
more a little more abstract so you know
but but I'm going to split the
conversation here into actually I think
I've said here
two things process and product so I
would just like to review process a
little bit and then we'll talk about
product so process is more about how we
generate our data product and then
product is we'll talk about
characteristics of that actual data so I
was I in preparing for this talk I
actually listen to layer of this paper
but I found this a reference to this
very nice paper here which you know I
think the paper outlined ten simple
rules for reproducible computational
research and looking through these rules
on it's actually quite good and I think
whose all of us to to look at this
checklist and think about it and when
you generate you were when you do your
computational work when you're doing
your big data analytics I'm you know
which parts of these things do you
actually do in your daily practice you
know if I have a little time towards the
end I'll show you some tools that we
build and we use our daily practice this
that actually make it really simple to
follow most of these ten rules so that's
kind of the work that we do is is how do
we make sure that everyone can easily
all these rules but even in the absence
of tools like the ones that we built
which I think are pretty spiffy but but
even in the absence of these tools these
are lessons that you can follow every
day and again maybe some of them are
obvious and hopefully um many of you who
are listening to this already do this um
and if you don't you should think about
well which one of these things could I
start doing tomorrow because they'll
impact my reproducibility so it's you
know simple things like I keep track of
the how you produced every result right
so that could mean write it down that
could mean create a spreadsheet that
could mean use provenance tracking tools
that that you know like Python notebooks
or our notebooks those are potentially
ways of keeping track
how data was produced but then you also
need to be a little bit careful why
don't go back and rewrite some dolls
previously on you know so you still need
to kind of keep track of things avoiding
manual data steps things you do manually
are hard to reproduce and impose those
errors keep track of all the things that
you use external programs keep track of
the version numbers that you generated
the data with and for things you develop
yourself please use github or some other
version control system to keep track of
what you're doing so you know how your
did was produced I mean three is quite
interesting there was recently a public
I think was fairly widely published that
there was a bug discovered and one of
the standard fMRI analysis libraries it
was producing wrong results and there
were so the bug was fixed but there's a
large number of publications that were
created using this software module for
doing it from your eye analysis for
which there was a bug for which we have
no idea which papers are now invalid
because we don't know the version number
that was used to produce those results
so that's an example of three on number
five is kind of going to this whole
lifecycle they don't throw away the
intermediate results everything is
important every step along the way it's
important so track all the storage is
cheap these days so keep all the
intermediate results don't just keep the
final result six I'm a little less
interested there and if you're doing
random things you want to you know know
how your random number generator was
seated never said always keep your raw
data don't just give us the plot give us
the data behind the plot presumably with
all the history of how it was generated
allow you to consume in and out of your
data that's eight number nine is is if
you have analysis or tax you always want
to connect them to the underlying
results to the data and we're going to
talk
next about how one might go about a
connecting textual statements like
publications to the underlying results
and then 10 we're also going to talk
about shortly which is we need to
provide access to the scripts runs and
the results right because transparency
is the key to reproducible science so
those are some things that impact
process how do we go about producing our
data again I think there's some takeaway
here if you're not checking off you know
seven eight or nine of these things and
what you're doing today you know go back
after this lecture think about what can
I do that to increase the number of
these things that I'm doing alright so
now let's talk a little bit about the
product itself in the data what
properties would we like the data to
have that come out of for example the
extensible rules that are going to
promote this notion of reproduce
abilities so that we can find data so
that we know what how it was produced so
that we can have a chance of
regenerating the method and then so we
can reuse that data as the foundation to
do to do new things
now what's come out of kind of a
community of people who care about these
things kind of every day they come in
and out and they think about data and
running repositories and curating data
what's emerged actually out of an
organization called force 11 is this
notion that data should have some basic
properties and we should we say that we
want our data to be findable accessible
interoperable and reusable and I'm going
to go through each of these things in
more detail but these are called the
fair criteria or fair guiding principles
so what we would like is our data to be
fair now if you haven't heard of this
these Fair principles you have now and
you should be aware of the fact that
these are gaining increasing traction
across kind of the two things
you probably do care about one is that
the NIH is increasingly adopting and
pushing fair principles and driving that
in to the grants and into repositories
where you're required to deposit your
data when you're done the other thing is
that scientific journals are
increasingly concerned about
reproducibility
in imposing elements of fair principles
on the submissions to these journals so
in spite of the fact that it's the right
thing to do there are also kind of
self-serving reasons why you want your
data to be fair because you're going to
need it to get money and you're gonna
need it to publish your results and the
reason why it's the right thing to do is
because it's those results you get are
going to be higher impact and have a
better chance of being correct so and
I'd also like to make the point that
often when we talk about fair data it's
it's attractive think that oh that's
just something for the repository people
to worry about that's just something you
know that I need to worry about when I
publish my data now I think the benefit
of fair data applies throughout the
process so I'm creating the data to the
end to the point of publication so fair
data helps us achieve the ten simple
rules and if you remember back on the
earlier slide lack of reproducibility
was due to me not being able to
reproduce my own results and so if we
think about fair as something that's
good throughout the process we're going
to go after that issue of can I even
reproduce my own results so that's good
for the general community their point of
publication at some level is good for
you as you're doing computational
science so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to drill down and we're going to
look at kind of what the definition of
fair actually means in order to
understand so fair is written by kind of
this data curation data library did
management community and for those I'm
assuming most of you
this call aren't active participants in
that community so there's some jargon or
some background stuff that I think that
you need to have a basic understanding
of in order to actually read kind of the
fare principles and understand them so
if you'll indulge me for for a few
minute it's what I'd like to do is just
reduce some of these background concepts
that maybe you're familiar with maybe
you're not and if you're not familiar
with them you don't have to be experts
in this but you should be aware bearing
these ideas and have a vague idea of
what they mean because I think they're
pretty important and they end up help
you structure your data methods so that
they're going to be more robust and
they'll be more oriented towards fair
and you'll have better reproducibility
on the results so the two concepts I'd
like to review before we dive into the
fare principles are the notion of
metadata and the notion of persistent
identifiers because these two concepts
kind of permeate the fare principles so
let's start with with metadata so I'm
actually going to take a little step
back and again this is something that
maybe you do implicitly in your work
it's always good to think about these
ideas explicitly because they help you
design better and have better
experimental design around computational
experiments so I want to introduce if
you're not familiar with this idea the
notion of a data model so a data model
kind of in the Information Sciences
literature is something that basically
describes the structure of the data and
the relationship between big pieces of
your game so a data model at a high
level talks about the things we care
about we care about samples and
measurements and assays and images and
sequences right those are examples of
things we care about and how an
attributes of those things so what are
the attributes that describe a
sequencing experiment for example and
then also we we often don't think about
this but the connection between them how
is a sample related to observations on
that
how does a simulation run relate to an
input data file um so it's it's things
and sometimes we call those entities its
attributes or properties of those things
and relationships between those things
and so if we have this underlying notion
of a data model which describes kind of
the structure of the information another
term people often use is that's a
knowledge model it kind of represents
the knowledge the connection the
structure of what we care about so the
term metadata which I'm sure you've all
heard of is really just so we often say
metadata is data about the data so what
does that mean so it's a structured set
of attributes that describe our data in
other words it's it's the data model so
the metadata is basically the data model
that describes the structure and
contents of our data so when we think
about metadata what we first need to do
to think about what's our metadata what
are the things that I care about how do
I describe them and how are they
connected and then I can take those
descriptions and use that to both find
data that I'm interested in and figure
out what's in there so I can reuse it
now there are many different ways we can
create these also ways of notating these
things so you might have heard or you
know a lot about these things so things
like the entity relation model that's an
example of a way we might describe this
or the resource description framework is
another example so these are common
tools used for creating data models and
which means that these have become tools
by which we create metadata so let me
just give you a little example so this
is an example from one of the
repositories of long response before so
this is on face base so it's a
repository for looking at a
cranial-facial dysmorphia and it's
fairly broad we've got imaging data
we've got we've got a kind of more
facial morphology we've got RNA sequence
data a gene expression data we've got
micros
Ct all kinds of things so here's on the
left a picture of the simplified view of
our data model and notice it's
structured so we have the idea of me on
a project which is creating multiple
datasets each dataset might have a
sample for each sample we have multiple
assays each essay is could have one or
more or files or we could just have
files that are directly into a attach to
a data set so this is our data model if
you look at the right-hand side of the
picture you see a slightly more detailed
view of this so you'll notice we have
now four types of pass A's imaging
clinical bioinformatics and enhancer
essays we have lots of different types
of files so we can have bam files
fasting files TIFF files etc so this is
this notion of data model and then so
when we talk about metadata in this
context essentially what we're doing now
is for each of these boxes we have a set
of properties and attributes that
describe these things and that now
becomes our metadata so for a project we
might have something like the project
thing we might have the principal
investigator for file we might have the
data type file format the date the file
was obtained the the the instrument was
obtained from so that that's an example
now all our metadata and data okay so
that's concept one um that that you
should have some familiarity and comfort
with second concept I want to introduce
is the notion of identifier and I'm the
material I'm presenting now there's a
number of papers that are out there the
material I'm showing now is from a very
nice kind of blog posting called Ben I
bad identifier about potholes of the
information superhighway so an
identifier on it most basic it's nothing
more than a name person so if I have
something that I care about um I can I
can it's it's often useful and very
important to be able to name that thing
being away and there's lots of different
ways I can name things so it turns out
if you think about this for a while
there there are lots of reasons why I
might want to do that in characteristics
that I might want to have so this
cartoon here gives you an example of
some of the reasons why I might want to
being an aim and some of the properties
of the name so and some of these maybe
you've already run across in your own
work I'm sure probably everyone on this
on this has probably made up names and
they might be bad names or they might be
good names so let's look at some of
these properties and so this is
basically showing I this cartoon is
basically showing the use of the name
from several perspectives so from the
basic researcher you know if I want to
reproduce something and that you get
different results well maybe I've
actually got the wrong physical thing
that I'm trying to you know reproducers
fault from maybe the mouse has got a
different genotype maybe I'm actually
using a different antibody um so how do
I know that I actually use the same
stuff or use the same program or produce
the same answers that another
investigator did so having a robust name
can help that if you've got two
published paper there's and they're
using the same data center in the same
gene the same analysis how do I know if
I have used that I've done an analysis
with a standard piece of software how do
I know you know these two people who
produce the result actually use the same
thing so naming is important for doing
that from the perspective of we'll skip
is this should dependent perspective I
don't think there's too many physicians
on this call but there's plenty of
bioinformatics researchers here so how
many times will we all see broken links
we say oh here's the name of this thing
here's the URL on the website and
they'll use it it doesn't work anymore
you know I can tell you as the operator
of repositories before we took over
people were just embedding links to the
website in their in their papers
published papers right and so you go to
try to
ruffridge something that's in this
published paper and you get a you know
can't find your did they use the same
protocol that I use so it was the same
algorithm used the same code used when I
could publish the result and then um
finally this last thing in you know
things are named and I have a better
chance of not only reusing them but then
tracking that other people are using
that so there will want to report
results so these are all reasons why we
might want to have a name so names could
be tricky I mean if we think through
them there's kind of there can be a lot
of complexity and we have to be really
kind of explicit as to what we intend
the names being used for and how we
create this thing so here's a real world
example there's an ID 9606 which
depending on how you're interpreting it
could be everything from the name of a
species to to a name of the bacteria to
a certain chemical right so all these
things have been assigned i need under
9606
so that's not a very good name you know
if I if I assign this thing and I say
OU's 9606 and you don't even know what
it's referring to so and this is a
real-world example um and if you look at
this paper that I referred to they they
they go into more detail about about
this particular example so what are some
properties that we would like names to
have so in general we would like a name
to be globally unique so that that one
it's one name refers to one thing so
this is this notion of globally unique
and this is what we call it identifier
um so the name refers to just one thing
that that name um that I can use that
name to somehow find or locate or get my
hands on that thing so that's something
you refer to as being actionable
on and that would be great if that made
always worked at some level so that we
could always use this name and find
something out about the about the thing
that were referring to and the term we
use for that is we call those
identifiers persistent or permanent way
to think about this in the physical
world is if we go to a library each book
has an ISBN number and that ISBN number
always refers to that book and even if I
can't get ahold of the book at least I
can get some information about that book
like where in the Shelf it will be
located if it exists who the author was
when it was published things like that
now you've probably in your practice
seen things like on this thing in
citations or papers or when you go this
thing it says doy DOI that stands for
digital object identifier so that's an
example of identifier that has these
properties so there's this whole kind of
structure an infrastructure that's been
built to make sure that those doors are
globally unique they only refer to one
thing they're actionable which is I can
use that that door I can kind of plug it
into a web browser or get back
information about what is referring to
and there's this whole financial
business structure built up so that I'm
guaranteed that a toy always works so
the idea is a hundred years from now I
should be able to result what we say
there's all the doy it get back
information about that data or that
publication even if that data or
publication no longer exists indoors or
in crete usually be using now not just
for publications but for data as well so
that's an example of identifiers and
here's just a picture if we look at this
this is a example of a citation I don't
see hopefully you can see my mouse right
here so if you see this thing here that
thing that starts with HTTP colon slash
slash Z thing and that o our G slash
then Z can colon all that stuff so that
is the example of a persistent
identifier that uniquely identifies a
piece of data in this
um and that's you know what's called
actionable um so those are I could cut
that into a web browser and I will get
back information about about that
particular piece of data and this other
one here is another example of a type of
identifier so this is an identifier
that's actually not resolved or turned
there into an action by Z fin but it's
by the California digital library is
actually resolving that all right so
that's our background information so now
we can look in a little more detail when
we say thumping is there what does that
mean
so so what does it mean for something to
be findable so for something to be
findable intuitively that means if we
kind of know something about it we can
locate it out of this vast sea of data
we need to be able to actually get the
discover which piece of data were
interested in and so this is going to
focus on two things one of which is
we're going to have some metadata that
describes this thing so that we know
we've got something that's interesting
and we need to name that metadata so
we're gonna name that better date with a
globally unique persistent identifier so
I'm gonna have identified it's going to
name a collection of metadata that
metadata point to is going to describe
what's in our data with rich metadata
and interpret rich metadata to say I've
got an interesting data model that
describes what I've got that metadata is
then searchable so we've taken it and
we've registered it and so we can look
for things you know based on
characteristics of the data and then
finally that the data itself has a
persistent global unique identifier so
we can name and refer to the metadata
that we used to describe the data we can
name and refer to that data Oh globally
and persistently and uniquely and then
we've got a rich rich model that allows
us to find things that they're
interested in so that's the
ah findable right so kind of takeaway
lessons here is as you're creating data
and intermediate products and
publications think about can I give it a
name that's unique can I describe it
with metadata should I kind of name the
metadata should I be naming um should I
be naming the data should I be how
should i search for it and then you
might want to think about findability
into the tools that you use every day so
what is nine metadata is it the file
name is it a spreadsheet do I think
about explicitly what attributes I want
to have for this thing so that I have a
model or do I just kind of make stuff up
when I stick it in the file name so
those are all things we can take away on
a daily basis to be accessible that has
to do with once I found it can I get my
hands on the numbers can I get my hands
on this stuff I'm interested in and this
speaks to this notion of open science
and the notion that transparency is good
for reproducibility in science of course
we all know that there are reasons why
not every piece of data can be
accessible for IP reasons for privacy
reasons for dating use agreement reasons
but in general what we would like to say
is that at least the metadata I'm
talking about our our results should be
retrievable given the identifiers for a
collection of metadata I should be able
to use a standardized protocol to get my
hands on that metadata and these days
what that means is I should be able to
use the web protocols or HTTP to
retrieve the metadata in a way that I
can interpret so that means it comes
back and not just in raw text but may be
structured using like CSV format or JSON
or something like that that the protocol
is open free and universally
implementable on so again that says
something like HTTP that the protocol
allows for authentication and
authorization where necessary so that
says we can protect it and that we
separate the notion of accessibility of
the metadata from the data so we should
be able to know something
about the existence of a piece of data
in some level of the characteristics of
that data even if we can't access the
data or or know what's available right
so if you think about if I go to DB gap
I can search and discover you know what
would what genotypes are available even
if I can't get my hands on the genetic
data and then these other things say and
I should be able to go through something
like HTTP protocol and query that
catalog and find this stuff I shouldn't
hide it behind the priory interface
so essentially metadata should be free
it should be widely accessible to be
used to be able to get to it using
standard non-restricted protocols and
then we can address the question as to
whether you get to the data or not to be
interoperable so where I so we want the
metadata to be structured in a way that
I can interpret and so what that means
is often we're going to express metadata
using standard representations in things
that you probably heard this ontology
term or vocabulary so we're going to
have standard ways of describing the
metadata and the relationship between
the pieces of the metadata will
typically tend to use a formal way of
describing that so things like the
earlier I talked about entity relational
or more commonly we use this thing
called the resource description
framework or RDF is a way of describing
our metadata and we might render that
into lots of different mechanisms maybe
or representations maybe you've heard of
this thing called json-ld so that would
be an example of that and that our
metadata will refer potentially to other
metadata so this is this notion that
that we're not going to have everything
in one metadata record we might refer
off to other pieces of metadata and so
this allows us to to get a description
of a piece of data or even the data
itself and to be able to interpret it so
we know if it's well well what
how it was created work painful okay and
lastly we want our data to be reusable
so that means first of all we have to
document their data with enough kind of
details that are correct so that so that
we know we've got what we're interested
in we would like a clear statement of
reuse properties of that data so this is
thus notion of muses license so like for
example creative commons as an example
is an example of a usage license and so
you should declare that explicitly you
want some history of how the metadata
and they were produced and so that's
this notion of provenance
so you want to know what protocols or
methods were used so you know if you
should be a literally use it and then
lastly some of these things that there
are community standards that are defined
for these metadata and data a should
adhere to that so for example geo or
encode define community standards for
RNA seek data in how you should describe
your RNA seek experiments so that's an
example of the main relevant community
stands around metadata so these are the
ideas behind fair data principles and so
that the low level details of this are
maybe not germane to you but I think
it's worthwhile to keep these ideas in
the back of your mind as you're
designing your experiments and designing
your data and all adhere to it so let me
just very briefly give you an example of
how we've applied some of these things
in the work we're doing an art bb2k
center so some tools were playing fair
just to give you a hint for for how you
could apply some of these things in
practice so within the BDS center of
excellence we've developed kind of three
tools that help promote fair data
creation in exchange and I'll just very
briefly run through them so there are
these things we call a Big Data Bad
which promotes access
and findability
this thing called a research object
which is defines a metadata model and
helps promote findability and
interoperability and then something we
call a minimal identifier which meets
kind of a bunch of these permanent ID
requirements that show up in their
documents so I'll just go through this
very briefly to give you just an idea of
how some simple things can help promote
fair so we've created a packaging format
or a way of collecting up a collection
of related data and then describing that
data in ways that promote access and and
and and interoperability so in some
sense a BD bag there's nothing more than
a fancy zip file where we've enumerated
the structure and defined what needs to
be in that zip file and one of the most
important things we include is what's
called a manifest which basically lists
the set of files you expect to see and
records the contents using arm check
sums so a manifest lists all the
contents and check sums and then we've
also designed this for big data so it
might include data that we don't
actually have available to us but a
referenced by identifier but we have the
ability to enumerate all these potential
contents and know exactly what should be
included in there so this gives us a
convenient way of collecting up and
exchanging data we use something called
research objects which are rich metadata
so we include this this is an example
and research object is basically a
metadata model in some vocabulary that's
been designed to support
interoperability
so this is an example of metadata using
a research object and what we see here
is for example this is defining the file
type using a
the research object formalism and so
this is a format called JSON LD and and
this is using the a RDF underlying
metadata model and then the last piece
is we've created in this structure that
makes it really easy to create permanent
identifiers for any arbitrary piece of
data or intermediate data so rather than
you having to go and talk to somebody
and belong to an organization and have
somebody meant to die for you which is
like what you have to do now we've
leveraged something operated by the
California digital library and provided
the ability for you to just at the
spoiler moment create a unique
identifier for a piece of data and to
associate enough metadata with it so you
know exactly what you're talking about
who created it and when it was created
so now you can resolve that and this is
an example of where you get back you
know in following the fair principles
we've now taken this identifier we've
resolved this back to a specific set of
metadata so let me just give you an
example of how we might bring this all
together very quickly so here's a little
a use case that we've done with the
encode data so in this case our primary
data source is encode we want to do some
computation on data that exists in the
code repository and you can go to encode
and you can search and you can get back
a list of things and then you can go and
you can download each of these things
and store it in a local directory and
and then hope you've downloaded all the
right files and if you want somebody
else to reuse this data they have to go
and redownload that same set of files so
that obviously does not promote
reproducibility so applying some fair
principles to that we have used our
tools to basically take an encode search
and turn that into one of our bag
structures arm so now basically we've
enumerated all the results we've
captured metadata about all those
results we
then associating the unique name to this
collection and then we bind an
identifier to that collection which is
actionable so now I can use an exchange
this identifier I can go and retrieve
metadata about that collection I can
retrieve that collection and then use
that to access the data so that I know
that I've accessed exactly the right
collection of data in exactly the right
version of data so now I have the
ability to start to have reproducibility
by applying these fair principles using
these two links to expect computational
experiments that I might want to do on
encode so I'm gonna stop now that gives
us a few minutes for questions so just
the takeaway that we should always be
concerned about reproducibility it's
something that should inform your data
practice I'm it's not that hard to
introduce notions of reproducibility
into your analytic processes you should
always use version control you should
always write scripts you should always
keep your intermediate results you
should always think about how you're
gonna identify things in unique way so
we just need to practice computational
processes that promote reproducibility
and we should keep in the back of our
mind that even if it's just for
ourselves or our commedia collaborators
that we would always like our data to be
findable accessible interoperable and
reproducible it's not just something we
should care about when we publish we
should think about how we can do this
every day there are tools like the BDS
tools that are available to help you do
that
it doesn't have to be hard it's
something that's just good to do and
it's becoming increasingly something
that you're going to need for for
funding and publication so whether you
want to do it or not you're going to be
forced to do it
so with that I'm going to stop there's a
few minutes for questions um and thank
you for your time and hopefully
attention thank you
for customer for this great talk so a
couple of questions but first there was
a comment from the audience which was
that in certainly the discussion of fair
and and data management and the data
processes one of the sort of under
looked resources that that people often
often failed fail to recognize is a
great resource for helping with a lot of
these processes are your librarians um
so I think librarians particularly at
academic medical centers and other
universities are increasingly involved
in the data management processes of both
Big Data and other sorts of data
repositories so for those in the
audience and and looking at data
management issues I think going to your
librarian is certainly a good good thing
because they can also provide a lot of
insight um so one question that has come
up is what about context and secondary
piece of data in terms of both primary
and data secondary analysis and so you
sort of emphasize this at the beginning
of your talk with respect to describing
what the data is how to get to it and as
such but I think one of the challenges
that particularly in the biomedical
space is we often have datasets where
the data is not collected primarily the
data is collected for a primary usage
such as maybe clinical care or something
else and then it's being accessed or
analyzed for sort of secondary purposes
and trying to understand what the
content or context is around the
original intent of the data is often
undocumented do you have any thoughts on
on how fair and answer to the annotation
processes and and all that and sort of
be interwoven into that yeah I think
that's a that's a good question there so
secondary use is always a challenge and
you know as it was so there a couple
ways you could approach that so one is
to design you know depending on the
reason for production of the data to
design
secondary use of mine and so some things
like these repository studies that I
have that is the primary motivation so
we can do that work upfront you know in
terms of kind of serendipitous secondary
use you know one would like to make the
argument that that if you're doing fair
for your own primary use that that would
allow at some level interpretation for
secondary reuse and if you are capturing
that as part of your just good data
practices then that will that will help
facilitate reusability however at the
end of the day I mean there is this
problem which is that it's got to be as
we say buyer beware right so there has
to be enough documentation to determine
whether the data is accurate enough of
valid enough for whatever secondary use
you might want to apply it to so there's
no magic bullet
sometimes you need so much detail that
eight secondary is really difficult I
think if we improve our data hygiene
kind of as part of daily practice I
think the ideas that would help
facilitate secondary use of data so
always you know it's always just a good
idea to think about if there are two
ways to do it you know be better to do
it the way that might facilitate
somebody to reuse this and in any case
we still have the reproducibility
requirement so let's get second primary
use of the data right somebody else
needs to be able to reproduce your
analysis reproduce your analytics so
that the results could be validated
great so another question which has come
up is a bit more technical so the
question has to do with BB bag and
they're asking specifically how does
beauty bag
differ maybe conceptually from what you
might have in your classic tar file
structure from Linux and basically the
idea with the manifests that you haven't
ours and the associated information that
that's linked into the manifest he sort
of provide some clarification on that
yeah so there's a couple of things on
that one is the the manifest concludes
checksums not every arm file that's in
the bag has to be included in the EE bag
so we have the idea of embedded
references um so that's to facilitate
big data there's a little more
structuring information about files so
for example the name of the manifest is
explicit it's it's actually one of the
files in the in the in the bag or the
other thing is there's an RFC emerging
for bag structure it's not it's not
rocket science it's pretty simple it's
just saying let's agree on some basic
structure the manifest file what goes
into the manifest how they day they
should be organized on within the
archive and then let's build some
tooling that allows us to do things like
you know generate the checksums generate
the proper manifest fetch the data that
might be distributed things like that
there there is a paper and there's a
nice website with all these things on it
and if there's any questions on that
please follow up with me great so and
last question really quickly um do you
re aware of or any particular resources
or tools to the chief fare right so
there are lots of tools so fare itself
is a set of principles it's not an
implementation guideline so you know
tools are some combination to the policy
and then so for example there's the is a
tool set that allows you to create
reusable data collections around
investigations there are the various
tool tools and services that are
emerging for creating identifiers like
mayonnaise or some of the other tools
there are tools for helping create and
do annotations
around metadata so you know I think
there are things like bio caddy um which
is been creating the the bd2k program
that defines interoperable metadata
models and search indexes things like
that
so there's no one tool I think it's
awareness of kind of what goes into it
the underlying principles and then being
more explicit about your practice so
that you kind of conform to these
principles and again that practice could
be I know it's got to go in a repository
that's because that's a condition of
funding and my repositories are
organized around fair or it's just like
I'm doing an investigation in my lab and
this would be a good thing for me to do
so let me think about you know what is
up my strategy going to be for
findability and and then what tools that
are available could I use within my
experiment to make things findable other
than maybe coming up with a fancy
filename right or a nested directory
structure so you know that's what I
would say I think awareness is the first
thing and then then select the things
that are right you don't need a
sledgehammer for everything you do so
you could do just kind of lightweight
stuff being aware of it and just being
cognizant as you decide your your
protocols your computational protocols
great so we're at 10 o'clock I'd like to
thank you again for this wonderful
presentation and slowly the discussion
so thank you very much ok thank you all
for your attention